So if you asked a billion believers what sits at the absolute center of their faith, I mean, almost all of them would point to two things without hesitation.
Yeah, they'd point to the historical messenger who arrived with the divine message and the revelation or scripture that messenger carried.
Exactly.
That instinct is just so deeply ingrained in our collective consciousness.
We assume the bringer of the book and the book itself must be the undisputed starting line of reality.
We do.
It's natural to think that way.
But
What if that hierarchy is completely upside down?
And that is exactly what we are exploring today for you, the listener, as we unpack A profound historical treatise called Establishing the Imitai.
It was written by the brilliant scholar, Anis Aburi.
Yeah, and just to keep things smooth as we navigate his pretty intricate philosophical architecture.
We will simply refer to him as the author from here on out.
This text really demands that you rethink the very geometry of belief.
I mean, it argues with incredible force that the I am a mate, the continuous presence of the living guide, is not some secondary supplementary role that comes after the message.
It flips the whole script.
Yeah.
The author presents it as the supreme office of existence, like the absolute center of the religion, outranking even the historical messenger.
The imit is the pole and foundation of religion.
that never lapses while the messenger comes and goes.
That is just a massive paradigm shifting statement.
It really is.
And we are going to unpack that radical priority from the ground up.
Yeah, we are going.
To explore how the author argues that human nature itself proves this structure must exist.
And then, perhaps most fascinating of all, we will witness how he calls upon the physical universe to testify to this.
The cosmos above us and the earth below us.
He uses them to act as an unforgeable witness to this reality.
But he doesn't start with vague theological concepts, does he?
No, not at all.
He carves 2 very specific, highly physical images into the mind of the reader to describe this office.
He uses the language of physics and architecture to anchor us.
Okay, so what's the first image?
The first term he introduces is KOTB, the pole.
He wants us to visualize the fixed pivot that a heavy millstone turns on.
Oh, I see.
So if you picture a traditional millstone, you have this massive crushing weight of rock grinding grain.
Exactly.
The kinetic energy involved is immense.
The millstone revolves continuously doing the heavy necessary work of the world.
But it can only do that work safely and effectively because there is a single perfectly still point in the very center, which is the pivot.
Because if you remove that central pivot, all that kinetic energy instantly becomes destructive.
Yeah, the stone just flies off its axis and the entire structure tears itself apart.
The stillness of the pole is what allows the violent movement of the stone to have purpose and direction rather than just chaotic ruin.
And that physical reality mirrors the
religious reality.
So the spinning millstone of worldly and religious affairs would just disintegrate into chaos without a fixed living center.
That is exactly his point.
Then the second term he uses moves from mechanics to architecture.
the foundation of religion.
The foundation.
So you have to think of the buried courses of stone upon which an entire fortress is constructed.
Yeah, the stones you never actually see when you look at the building.
You admire the soaring walls, the intricate windows, the vaulted roof.
You don't look at the dirt and the buried foundation.
Yeah, without those hidden stones bearing the immense weight deep in the earth, nothing above them can stand for a single moment.
So the author is asserting that the living imam
is both the axis everything revolves around and the buried foundation everything rests upon.
Yes, around him the affairs of God's servants are governed and the land is set right.
And the author claims that without this foundation, three specific realities are completely lost to the believer.
Let's walk through those 3 realities because this is where the stakes of this treatise become incredibly high.
Well, none of these things arrive raw into the hands of a believer.
They all flow through this single structural channel.
The first of these three realities is tawhid, the absolute unity of God.
The highest, most abstract truth a human mind can reach for.
Exactly.
It is the absolute summit of religious knowledge, and yet it is incredibly easy for the human intellect to distort it if left unguided.
And the second reality?
The second reality is the historical message itself, the factual, grounded reality that God has spoken and sent a revelation into human history.
Okay, and the third?
The third reality is Tawil, the
interpretation of the sacred law.
Let's pause on that third one, the inner interpretation, because I feel like it highlights the mechanics of this dependency really well.
It does.
When we talk about the plain commands of religion.
The daily laws, the rituals, the physical actions required of a believer.
They can very easily become empty mechanical rituals.
If you only have the outer law, you are essentially just reading the sheet music.
But the inner interpretation is what actually unlocks the symphony.
It is the spiritual meaning
beneath the physical action.
Remove the guide and the entire structure collapses across all three of those levels.
So the highest truths regarding the unity of God become distorted by human projection.
And the history of the message loses its continuous anchor and fractures into competing narratives.
and the daily law has become hollow, mechanical burdens stripped of their inner meaning.
This is what it means to be a pole and a foundation.
A foundation isn't just one supporting wall among other walls.
No, it is the solitary thing upon which everything else depends to exist at all.
And the author makes it very clear that this architectural framework is not some rogue theory he invented in a vacuum.
Definitely not.
He anchors this structural necessity deeply in the traditions of the Prophet, peace and blessings of Allah be upon him and his.
That anchor is crucial for his audience.
We have to recall the famous tradition of the two weighty things.
Yes, the prophet is remembered as leaving behind the book of God and his kindred, his living family.
He tied them together in one breath.
declaring that the two shall never part from one another until they return to him.
Meaning the revelation was never meant to be this standalone, static document handed to humanity to decipher on our own.
It arrives permanently lashed to a living family.
Because a book, no matter how divine its origin, cannot answer back when a new century brings a new question.
A text can be misinterpreted, mistranslated, or deliberately manipulated by those in power.
The living guide is the active safeguard of the text, the one who carries its actual intended meaning forward through the friction of time.
Exactly.
Which is why.
Wait, hold on.
I have to stop you there because I am feeling some serious friction with this logic.
I don't buy that yet.
How can the guardian of the revelation outrank the one who brought it?
That's a very fair question.
I mean, inherently, the guy who delivers the law, the founder of the entire system, has to be the CEO, doesn't he?
It seems completely counterintuitive, almost disrespectful to the historical timeline, to say the keeper of the book is more central than the bringer of the book.
That is a highly rational skepticism, and it is exactly the objection the author anticipates.
Addressing it reveals the very core of the classical Ismaili reading.
Okay, so how does he address it?
He meets this head on by surfacing our first central tension.
We can call this tension.
The imam before the messenger.
He doesn't shy away from the paradox.
He provides 3 brilliant, linked reasons to defend this tension and prove why the continuous office is the larger, more comprehensive affirmation.
Okay, let's break down those three reasons.
How does he justify putting the guardian above the founder?
The first reason is a matter of containment.
The author argues that affirming the imit already automatically affirms the messengership because whoever knows the imam knows the messenger.
Oh, so the larger circle inherently contains the smaller circle?
Precisely.
If you acknowledge the living guide, you have in that very act already acknowledged the historical messenger whose law that guide is actively upholding.
Because you cannot guard a revelation that doesn't exist.
Recognizing the guardian proves
you already accept the existence of the revealer.
But it doesn't work in reverse.
A person can accept that a historical messenger arrived, accept the historical book as a static artifact, and stop right there.
They can completely miss the living guide standing right in front of them in their own era.
That asymmetry is the key.
Proving the imit proves both, but proving only the messengership leaves you short of continuous guidance.
Therefore, the office of the guide is the larger, more encompassing reality.
That makes sense.
What is the second reason?
The second reason he offers is about the audience and understanding which battlefield the intellect actually needs to fight on.
Which battlefield?
Proving the existence of a historical messenger is an argument you make to outsiders.
You make it to polytheists or people who stand entirely outside the religion and have never heard the summons.
But to the people who are already inside the faith, the historical messenger is an established, universally accepted fact.
The real conflict is inside the house.
Exactly.
Believers inside the community are not drawing swords over whether the historical messenger existed.
They are arguing, often violently, about who the true guide is right now.
The real intellectual labor, the debate that must be won with evidence and profound reasoning rather than just historical assertion
revolves entirely around the living guide.
You prove the messenger to the outsider, but you must prove the guide to the believers who are already inside but fiercely divided.
That frames it perfectly.
The author is focusing the intellectual energy on the most vital active dispute.
Which brings us to the third reason.
And this one feels like it carries the most ontological weight.
It is the deepest of the three.
The third reason is about the permanence of the office.
The author states that the world can never, not for a fraction of a second, be without a living guide.
But messengers are different, right?
Messengers, however, are present at specific junctures and absent at others.
Prophecy comes in discrete historical cycles.
A prophet speaks, delivers a new law, establishes A framework, and then departs.
While the guide remains continuously,
A guidance that switches on and off, that exists brightly in one century but goes entirely dark in the next, cannot be the true foundation of reality.
Because a foundation has to always be there, bearing the weight of the structure above it.
Therefore, the office that is permanently, continuously present must inherently be more fundamental than the office that only appears sporadically to deliver law.
That is a staggering way to view human history.
I mean, prophecy is almost like a specialized task.
a massive world-altering task, but a specific one that occurs only when a new law is required by a new era.
But the underlying eternal state of the world requires the constant unbroken presence of the guide.
So how does he prove that prophecy is just a phase?
To prove that prophecy is a phase while guidance is the eternal state, the author asks us to look at how these massive titles trade places within scripture itself.
He points out a fascinating textual detail.
What detail?
God called Ishmael a messenger as recorded in chapter 19, verse 54.
So Ishmael holds the specific title of messenger.
But contrast that with Abraham.
Look at the famous address to Abraham in chapter 2, verse 124, where God says, indeed I am appointing you an imam for all humanity.
The author is very careful to point out that this supreme title was bestowed upon Abraham only at the very end of his life, long after he had already completed all his arduous work as a messenger.
That completely shifts the traditional Sunday school timeline.
We tend to think of these titles as synonymous, or we assume a prophet is the highest possible rank.
But this implies the title of Imam was not Abraham's starting point.
It was his ultimate destination.
It was the crown he earned after passing a lifetime of severe, crushing trials.
To reinforce how monumental the shift is, the author cites A profound tradition from the 6th Imam, which outlines this exact ladder of ascent.
How does that ladder work?
It details how God
as a servant, then elevated him to a prophet, then elevated him to a friend, then elevated him to a messenger, and only at the very end, at the absolute summit of this grueling progression, declared him an imam for all humanity.
That makes the mechanics of the hierarchy undeniable.
Messengership is a crucial step on the ladder.
But it's not the top rung.
Prophecy is a wave that rises up out of the ocean when the historical moment requires a new law to be spoken.
It crashes onto the shore of history, reshaping the landscape.
But guidance, the emmett, is the deep, silent, abiding ocean that the wave ultimately returns to.
The wave subsides,
but the ocean remains.
This unbroken continuity is exactly what the first imam, peace be upon him, taught his closest confidants.
The father of imams outlined this eternal presence beautifully, didn't he?
Taught that the earth is never, for a single fraction of a moment, left without one who stands for God with a proof.
Sometimes that proof is manifest, publicly known, and acknowledged by the world.
And sometimes that proof is fearful and hidden due to the danger of the era.
But the proof is always present, ensuring that the clear signs of the divine are never entirely lost to humanity.
So the commander of the faithful makes it clear that a hidden proof is still a structurally present proof.
Even if the majority of the world does not recognize him or cannot see him, the buried foundation is still actively holding up the fortress.
And this establishes his teaching as the absolute cornerstone for the author's entire worldview.
Exactly.
But wait, if this office is a permanent fixture of reality,
There must be evidence for it beyond historical texts, because as you said earlier, the emmet is the pole and foundation of religion, the office that never lapses while the messenger comes and goes.
And the author confirms this by moving the argument to an entirely new, incredibly expansive landscape now.
Which takes us out of the realm of pure scripture and into the realm of nature, human psychology, and intellect.
He begins to ground this necessity in our innate constitution and in the fundamental laws of how societies organize themselves.
He argues that this need is written into the very shape of the human mind.
To explain this psychological reality, he draws a brilliant parallel to the necessity of a creator.
Let's explore that parallel because the human mind's relationship with causality is fascinating.
Across almost every era, every isolated society, humanity universally looks at this complex, structured world and
that it must have a maker.
Yeah, the innate intellect naturally rejects the idea that a highly ordered system came from absolute nothingness.
People can see the necessity of a creator almost instantly.
But look at the chaos that unfolds immediately after that universal agreement.
As soon as people can see that a creator exists, they completely fracture over what that creator actually is.
They start reasoning based on their own biases, relying on flawed cultural traditions, and they end up falling into catastrophic philosophy.
The author details two very specific extremes of error here, demonstrating how the human mind fails when it tries to define the infinite on its own.
The first extreme is TASH BEH.
This is anthropomorphism.
People look at the physical world and reduce the creator to the things he created.
They say the creator is just a massive substance or the stars or the sun or they give him
physical limbs and location.
They dress the divine in human features until it just becomes another localized piece of the universe.
It is a psychological impulse.
We want something we can touch, something we can imagine within our own physical limitations.
So we shrink the divine down to our own size to make it digestible.
And then reacting to that error, others swing to the exact opposite extreme.
In their zeal to avoid anthropomorphism, they strip the creator of absolutely every attribute whatsoever.
They empty the concept out entirely until there is nothing left to relate to, nothing left to comprehend.
The divine becomes a total void.
So we have universal innate agreement on the existence of the creator followed immediately
by total ruinous disagreement about the reality of that creator.
And this brings us to the author's next major pivot.
He states that the exact same pattern, the exact same psychological fracture happens with the living guide.
This is our second central tension.
A necessity conceded, then contested.
So just like with the creator, people innately feel the structural need for an ultimate authority, a living summit in the human world to resolve disputes and interpret the law.
Grant the necessity of the role and then immediately draw swords over who actually fills it.
The philosophers look around at their academies and bestow the title of supreme guide on their smartest teachers, confusing intellect with divine authority.
The jurists claim it for themselves, believing that mastering the mechanics of the law makes them the ultimate authority.
And usurpers, oppressive rulers with massive armies but no spiritual right, steal the title by pure force to legitimize their political power.
But here is where I need to push back on the author's logic again.
That sounds like clever wordplay to me.
How so?
Well, if there's so many counterfeits running around, philosophers calling their tutors the ultimate guide, kings stealing the title at sword point, scholars claiming it based on memorization, doesn't that just mean the whole concept is an empty human projection?
You're saying the chaos disproves the role?
Yeah, if every misused title becomes proof, isn't it far more likely that human beings just have a psychological weakness for authority?
and the office itself is just a fiction we had event to comfort ourselves.
That is the exact cynical trap the intellect can fall into, and the author executes a brilliant inversion to dismantle it.
He argues that the dispute itself proves the structural reality of the office, not its falsehood.
How does the presence of 1000 fakes prove the existence of something real?
Because human beings do not fight over a throne that does not exist in reality.
Nobody bothers to impersonate a role that the structure of the world has no actual use for.
Think about the mechanics of counterfeiting.
People forge gold precisely because gold has intrinsic, undeniable value.
No one spends their life counterfeiting dead leaves or gravel.
The sheer volume of counterfeits in every single era, the endless multiplication of claimants and usurpers is actually the loudest, most undeniable evidence that human nature inherently demands this specific role.
That completely reframes the chaos of human history.
The crowd of pretenders isn't just noise drowning out the truth.
It is a compulsory chorus proving that a true guide must exist somewhere behind all the false ones.
Every tyrant reaching for the crown is inadvertently testifying that the crown must exist to hold society together.
But if history is flooded with these counterfeits, how does the listener actually navigate this?
What is the practical task of the individual seeking the authentic center?
The task of the seeker is a rigorous process of elimination.
You navigate this by systematically clearing away the counterfeits through recognizing their inherent limitations.
But the author warns that you must first set aside your own desires.
This is the hardest step because it is our own wish for an easy, flattering, or culturally convenient answer that keeps us clinging to false claimants.
We naturally gravitate toward a guide who tells us what we already believe or one who doesn't challenge our comfort.
Once you manage to set aside that desire, you use your intellect to observe the pretenders clearly.
You look at the philosopher, the jurist, the usurper, and you recognize their distinct deficiencies.
You see their lack of genuine, comprehensive knowledge when faced with a totally novel problem.
You see their lack of absolute piety when tempted by power.
You realize that a pretender is ignorant where the true guide must be knowing and shallow where the true guide must be endlessly deep.
You essentially take their own standards and show how they fail to meet them.
You chip away the false until only the true remains standing.
And you must undertake this exhausting labor because the stakes of following A counterfeit are existential.
As a poet wisely observed, whoever sets out on the road without a guide, a two-day journey stretches into 100 years.
A two-day journey stretches into 100 years.
That captures the tragedy of the counterfeit perfectly.
It is not just about moving slightly slower.
It is about wandering in endless circles in the dark, mistaking a mirage for the actual destination, and exhausting your entire life building on a foundation that will eventually collapse.
Which leads us to a profound causal transition in the author's treatise.
If finding the true guide requires this intense, fraught labor of clearing away false ones using our easily distracted intellects,
How does the universe itself assist us?
How does reality itself testify to the truth so we are not just left alone in a dark room with our competing philosophies?
This is where the text moves into its most beautiful and frankly its most mind-bending framework.
The author introduces the concept of the two parallel creations.
He posits a spectacular ontological reality.
God wrote two parallel creations.
One creation is made of physical bodies and the other creation is made of souls.
And these are not just vaguely poetically related.
They mirror each other point for point, function for function.
So everything that sustains the physical body in the visible, tangible world is actually a coded working blueprint for what sustains the soul in the invisible spiritual world.
The physical world is essentially A compulsory diagram designed specifically to teach us about the spiritual world.
The author applies this directly
of the heavens above us.
He points out a fundamental astronomical reality.
The physical body of the Earth and our own physical bodies are nourished and sustained by the turning of the celestial spheres.
The massive overarching orbits of the cosmos that dictate time and seasons.
Yes, but the spheres alone, the empty turning orbits of space,
bear no fruit on their own.
The physical world is entirely dependent on the stars and planets that are set within those spheres.
It is the specific light and the warmth of the stars that actually reach down, cross the expanse of space, and nourish the earth.
A sphere without a star is just empty, cold motion.
It provides structure, but no life-giving energy.
Now transpose that exact physical reality into the religious creation.
The prophets, the bringers of the historical message, are the massive, turning celestial spheres.
They create the vast framework, the overarching structure of the religious cycle.
Their law sets the boundaries of the era.
But the framework alone, the static law, is not enough to nourish the soul on a daily basis.
It is not.
The religious stars set within those massive prophetic spheres are the imams.
It is their specific light, their living knowledge, their active tawil.
that the soul actually feeds on to reach its spiritual perfection.
Just as a physical plant must photosynthesize the light of the physical sun to grow, the human soul must actively receive the spiritual light of the religious stars to survive and develop.
Wait, so we're supposed to believe that the entire vast physical universe
The actual stars, the planets, the mechanics of orbits, gravity, light was constructed by God just to serve as a coded diagram for this specific religious hierarchy.
I know it sounds massive.
Isn't that taking a metaphor to an absurd extreme?
It feels incredibly arrogant, like we were imposing a convenient human structure onto the immense indifferent cosmos.
I understand the resistance because modern minds separate physics from theology.
But you have to realize that for the author, this is absolutely not a metaphor.
It is not poetry used to make a point.
It is a stripped
ontological reality.
In his view, the physical elements, the literal stars burning in space, the literal spheres are merely compulsory passing symbols.
They are ephemeral.
They will eventually burn out and perish.
The spiritual realities they point to, the eternal hierarchy of guidance, are the chosen lasting truths.
So the physical universe is merely the shadow.
And the spiritual structure is the solid object casting that shadow.
The shadow only takes the shape of stars and spheres because the solid eternal object demands it.
The physical world was engineered specifically to reflect the spiritual reality, not the other way around.
The physical is the derivative.
The spiritual is the original.
Exactly.
I can see the sheer elegance of that system.
When you frame the ontology that way, the logic locks together flawlessly.
It really does.
If you accept the core premise that the physical world is a deliberate functioning mirror for the spiritual one,
then nature itself suddenly transforms.
It is no longer just a passive backdrop to human history.
It becomes an active, unforgeable courtroom.
And that brings us to the climax of his entire argument and our third central tension.
Two witnesses, one verdict.
The author frames the search for absolute truth as a legal proceeding of cosmic proportions.
Because in Islamic jurisprudence, judgment requires the testimony of two witnesses as outlined in chapter 2, verse 282.
One witness is not enough.
to secure a conviction or establish a definitive truth in court.
The author states that determining the absolute religious truth, specifically the truth of who the living guide is, also rests on the testimony of two distinct witnesses.
The first witness is set by law.
This is the realm of revelation, scripture, and reported historical testimony.
The texts, the traditions,
The words passed down from generation to generation, the historical record.
But the author acknowledges a stark, undeniable reality about human history.
Legal testimony can be tampered with.
Human beings are inherently fallible.
Texts can be corrupted by scribes, contexts can be intentionally lost, translations can be manipulated by empires, and words can be deliberately altered from their original places to serve a political agenda.
Which is exactly what causes the psychological fracture and the rise of all those counterfeits we discussed earlier.
People argue endlessly over the written witness because the written witness can be spun in 100 different directions.
And this is why the second witness is absolutely crucial for the survival of the truth.
When the legal testimony is tampered with or disputed by competing factions, the witness of nature steps into the courtroom.
And the witness of nature is compelled.
Compelled meaning it cannot lie, it cannot be bribed, and it cannot be edited by a king.
It is entirely incorruptible.
No human being, no tyrannical usurper, no clever philosopher.
can forge or edit the fundamental physical laws of the universe.
You cannot rewrite the relationship between the stars and the spheres to suit your political agenda.
You cannot forge the physics of a millstone and its pivot.
The physical cosmos testifies with perfect unbending consistency.
So when the historical text is murky, when the scholars are arguing and the usurpers are shouting, you look to the stars.
You look to the foundation.
You look to the unalterable blueprint of physical reality itself to verify what the tampered text was originally trying to say.
If the text claims a structure that violates the blueprint of nature, you know the text has been manipulated.
This is the absolute hinge for reading nature as proof.
It fulfills the divine promise that signs will be shown on the horizons and in the selves as stated in chapter 41, verse 53.
The horizons represent the macroscopic universe, the cosmos.
The selves represent our microscopic inner innate nature.
Both the vast outer universe and the intimate human soul are screaming the exact same structural truth.
When the legal text and the unforgeable laws of nature align, the truth of the guide becomes manifest with blinding clarity.
Two witnesses, one verdict.
If you are listening to this and mapping these concepts onto your own understanding of reality,
Consider the severity of what this framework implies for you personally.
It brings the stakes of these two parallel creations right down to the individual.
In the physical creation, if you deprive a body of the things it structurally needs, if you take away its physical nourishment, the light of the physical sun, the air it breathes, it suffers deeply and dies.
The physical body inevitably perishes when cut off from its source of life.
But, as the author points out, the physical body was destined to die anyway.
The loss, while tragic in the moment, is ultimately bounded by time.
But the reasoning that makes the Imam of the age the ever-present pole of the universe means that the spiritual creation operates on the exact same structural rules, but with eternal consequences.
A soul that is deprived of its true guide.
A soul that feeds on a counterfeit or wanders without the light of the religious stars faces a spiritual ruin that the body never risks.
The physical death is temporary, a mere transition.
The spiritual ruin, the wandering in the dark without the pivot, is lasting.
That is why the search for the genuine center cannot be abandoned and why the physical universe was built to point toward it.
The Imit is the pole and foundation of religion, the office that never lapses while the messenger comes and goes.
And so we are left with the final
unavoidable challenge of the author's architectural reality.
If the universe itself is testifying to a single unyielding center, and if human history is cluttered with elaborate comforting forgeries designed to distract you from it, which counterfeit are you still building your life on?